it's really it is difficult it's hard to
explain to you know five and a six
eighty seven year-olds what's going on
but but no the school's been creating
this abortion illness as well Kate
Middleton opening up about her struggles
trying to explain the corona virus
pandemic to her kids to William and Kate
really to be the front line Royals in
this national emergency in a rare move
the Duchess of Cambridge video chatted
with ITV Thursday morning photographs
we've got an amazing ability to tell a
story
the purpose for Kate's interview was to
promote her new hold still campaign in
collaboration with the National Portrait
Gallery ready what we hope people will
take inspiration through those
projectors is really just to try and
tell their part of a story from a
personal level to try and have showcase
and share what thank made you the 38
year old royal is known for taking
photos of her three children
George Charlotte and Louie but I'm very
much and now she's encouraging others to
do the same in an attempt to create a
collection of pandemic stories through
photos to document and share and a
moment in time I suppose that we're all
experiencing last month
Kate shared these colourful snaps in
honor of Louise birthday with the
caption Instagram versus reality the mom
of three says homeschooling is another
thing that hasn't been going according
to plan in the Cambridge household
George gets very upset he just wants to
love to show that it's project site
making satisfy to sandwiches as
the family has been in quarantine at
their Anmer Hall residents in Norfolk
England sits March but the Duchess says
they're regularly in touch with family
we hadn't done a huge amount to sort of
face time and faith schools and things
out there but obviously we're doing that
a lot more now and actually it's been
really great between this little check
in daily with family members and speech
them about news and things like that and
in some ways we've got a lot more
contact and not more face time than
perhaps we could have done before
William Kate will be doing what every
parent is trying to do right now giving
their children a sense of stability and
normality and trying to keep as much
routine as possible
[Music]